und dann sind wir bei kevin kühnert dem
stellvertretenden spd-vorsitzenden herr
kühnert diktatur sowie die sozialisiert
sind die menschen über die wir da reden
eigentlich nicht weil es sind nicht die
älteren das weisen die studien der uni
leipzig nach und andere auch das heißt
die menschen sind sozialisiert durch cdu
und spd regierungen in den neuen
bundesländern die bundesrepublik
deutschen volksparteien das hat die spd
falsch gemacht
zunächst mal totale zustimmung das ist
das woran ich mich gestört habe und
vielleicht eine bemerkung vorweg ich bin
31 jahre alt und in meiner
geburtsurkunde steht noch ganz knapp
westberlin drin das war dann aber nach
fünf monaten auch geschichte insofern
strittig heute nicht mit dem anspruch an
ostdeutschen zu erklären wie
ostdeutschland so ist sondern versucht
die letzten jahre viel zuzuhören und
versuche das jetzt auch wieder zu geben
und eine der erkenntnisse ist wer heute
im jahr 2021 im osten deutschlands lebt
ist entweder nach der wende geboren oder
hat neben der sozialisation im osten auf
jeden fall noch eine zweite nämlich die
vergangenen 30 jahre in der
bundesrepublik deutschland und der ganz
unterschiedlichen regierung und ich
glaube viele im osten sind einem
schicksal wenn sie so wollen zum opfer
geworden mich dass die wiedervereinigung
genau da stattgefunden hat wo sie
stattgefunden hat in eine phase hinein
in der so langsam sich der die ideologie
durchsetzte der markt wird das schon
regeln der staat ist zu fett jeder ist
seines eigenen glückes schmied als
lohndrückerei stattfand als plötzlich
tarifverträge nicht mehr die rolle
spielten genau in diese phase hinein hat
sich der arbeitsmarkt haben sich die
betriebe im osten neu organisiert
beziehungsweise wurden neu organisiert
und das ist ein rückstand den nicht aus
eigenem verschulden der menschen heraus
sondern aus strukturellen gründen man
bis heute hinterher hängt und ich würde
mich freuen wenn wir heute auch darüber
sprechen dass zum beispiel den letzten
zwei drei jahren was organisierung in
gewerkschaften arbeitskämpfe angeht die
ganz neue bewegung im osten erleben die
sie über 25 jahren nicht hatten und das
gibt auch grund zur hoffnung und zu mut
dass da eine selbstermächtigung schon
ein großes thema für die ostdeutschen
ist natürlich immer ihre repräsentanz
das wird angemahnt wir sind da im
einstelligen prozentbereich wenn es um
wichtige funktionen in einzelnen
institutionen betrieben prozent der
bevölkerung 15
um 5% aktionen der hören noch ist ja
keiner dran hätte geholfen erinnert wenn
die stellvertretende spd vorsitzende
klara geywitz geheißen hätte an der
seite von olaf scholz die haben sie mit
verhindert hätte zum beispiel auch eine
auszeit vertreten
die vorsitzende sehr ist sie aber als
vorsitzender haben sie sie verhindert
hätte es geholfen wenn auch da eine
bessere ostdeutsche repräsentanz in
ihrer partei gewesen wäre
so dürfen sich jetzt bei 10 prozent also
ich habe ehrlich gesagt wenn ich mich
und gucke wer die politischen gesichter
des deutschen ostens sind also da sehe
ich jetzt nicht meine partei als erstes
auf der schulseite dass wir da niemand
hervorgebracht haben wir stellen mit
manuela schwesig eine der beliebtesten
politikerinnen des landes wir haben eine
reihe ministerpräsidenten ob es matthias
platzeck ist oder andere hervorgebracht
die bis heute wichtige gefragte
gesprächspartner sind wir haben mit
franziska giffey eine
bundesfamilienministerin bis vor zwei
wochen gehabt jetzt tritt sie als
regierende bürgermeisterin in berlin an
was übrigens auch eine spannende
geschichte ist eine frau die im osten
deutschlands geboren und sozialisiert
ist und jetzt für die wieder
zusammengeführte stadt berlin als
regierenden bürgermeisterin kandidiert
also ich finde durchaus dass wir uns da
nicht verstecken fehler noch mal das war
die frage fehler sehen sie in der
historischen situation und in der spd
nicht trainer aber also wir kommen ja
immer wieder an dem punkt dass die
parteien im osten übrigens alle in
absoluten zahlen weniger mitglieder als
in den westdeutschen bundesländern haben
und dann möchte ich schon für meine
partei auch noch einmal daran erinnern
wir haben auch nicht aufgebaut auf
irgend eine blockpartei im osten weder
sind wir in die geschäftsstellen einer
blockpartei eingezogen noch haben wir
die mitglieder bestände übernommene
fällt es natürlich auch ein bisschen
schwieriger dann innerhalb von 30 jahren
ein großes personalreserve auszubauen
aus dem sid er heraus dann auch noch
eine ganze bundes partei mit einer
halben million mitglieder 30 jahre
würden vielleicht auch dafür etwas
gereicht haben alexander gauland ist bei
uns afd ehrenvorsitzender
sie sind helgoland das fand ich
interessant gebürtiger sachse chemnitzer
chemnitzer sie sind in sachsen geboren
waren 40 jahre über 40 jahre in der cdu
und sind seit 2017 fraktionsvorsitzender
in ihren augen sind wir jetzt im grunde
um im bild von herrn wanderwitz zu
bleiben nahtlos von der sed diktatur in
die merkel diktatur und in die korona
diktatur über ja das ist natürlich ein
ziemlicher unsinn was herr wanderwitz
das hat mich wunderts sowieso dass
jemand leute beschimpft um sie zum
wählen für sich anzustiften
ich glaube das ist nicht der richtige
weg ich glaube herr gysi hat einiges
völlig richtig gesagt die fehler in der
wiedervereinigung eine gewisse arroganz
im westen die aber leider sicher
fortsetzt die leute haben das gefühl das
ist nicht unser thema nehmen wir den
kenner sternen oder nehmen wir
identitätspolitik da hat herr haseloff
ja völlig richtig gesagt die leute das
geht völlig an den über die köpfe der
ostdeutschen hinweg auch für
westdeutsche aber vor allen dingen über
die köpfe der ostdeutschen und sie haben
das gefühl sie wie sie sind sozusagen
sie werden vorgeführt von westdeutschen
und genau das hat diese reaktion
ausgemacht dass sie auch protestieren
gegen das was sich da abspielt dass sie
nicht teil der entwicklung sind aber
wenn der herr wanderwitz das fest stellt
dann ist er natürlich teil des problems
und in keiner weise teil der lösung
interessant ist dass ich sie danach
überhaupt nicht gefragt herr gerland ich
wollte nämlich von ihnen wissen ob wir
jetzt in einer merkel diktatur
angekommen sind und sogar in einer
corona diktatur also ja wir sind und das
sagen nicht nur wir das sagen viele
mit der bundes not bleiben seinen weg
gegangen die er zumindestens sehr
gefährlich in richtung einer diktatur
geht und es gibt ja nun auch schon
wieder die überlegungen
wenn es dann mit corona vorbei ist dann
könnte man das klima auch noch mal
machen
also es gibt verfassungsrichter es gibt
touristen die jedenfalls große zweifel
haben dass das was gemacht worden ist
recht
sie haben im bundestag einer diktatur
auf widerruf verträgt sich nicht mit
unserer freiheitlich demokratischen
grundordnung jetzt sagen sie hier
das was wir mit der bundes notbremse
erlebt haben als bürger ginge schon sehr
in richtung einer diktatur das oder
lässt es eine diktatur das geht sehr in
richtung einer entwicklung dass das
parlament und aber auch die menschen
ausgeschaltet sind und nicht das gefühl
haben teil einer politischen entwicklung
sind die sie noch verstehen aber da war
jetzt das parlament dabei es gab eine
und gibt eine freie presse in diesem
jahr lang opposition in diesem land es
gibt eine debatte in der öffentlichkeit
darüber sie sagen wir sind kurz fertig
und es war lange das parlament nicht
dabei in dem bundesland sehr schnell zur
zeit geschehen das sagt ja nicht nur die
af die das sagen auch andere parteien
zum beispiel die fdp von daher
es ist verfassungsrechtlich jeden fall
sehr problematisch was gemacht worden
ist und die menschen haben das gefühl
dass sie auf dem weg in eine diktatur
sind natürlich dass man das überspitzt
formuliert und ich habe das wort
geomatik natur gebraucht da bin ich vom
eigenen parteivorsitzenden gerügt worden
das ist aber teil der politischen
auseinandersetzung und da habe ich auch
nichts davon sollten wir sind bei
melanie amann geschätzter journalistin
vom spiegel leitet das hauptstadtstudio
hier vor allem das ist hochinteressant
da trifft sich tatsächlich die fd auch
mit einer kritik von reiner haselhoff
der auch sagte diese bundes notbremse
ihm geschadet in sachsen-anhalt er hat
sie kritisiert und sagte das ist
förderer unsinn oder es tiefpunkt der
föderalen kultur trifft er sich da
tatsächlich mit der kritik der afg oder
geht die der afg weiter also da trifft
er sich überhaupt nicht denn das wasser
gauland sagt ist mit verlaub
hanebüchener unsinn zu sagen dass er
eine diktatur
wenn man einen mit dem im bundestag
beschlossenes gesetz das auch soeben vom
bundesverfassungsgericht
gebilligt wurde wurden anträge dagegen
zurückgewiesen also dass auf der einen
seite wo man dann einfach mal so das
wort diktatur in den raum stellt als
wäre das irgendwie so ein szenario mit
dem man herumspielen kann nach
populistischen belieben und andererseits
haseloff muss ich aber sagen er hat ja
auch sehr unglücklich agiert denn sein
land hat dass er mit getragen ist ja
nicht so als wäre dieses gesetz nicht
durch den bundesrat gegangen und hätte
hätte er das nicht mit unterstützt und
deswegen glaube ich auch dass die
wählerinnen und wähler in sachsen-anhalt
ihm das nicht abkaufen werden wenn er
jetzt also das wäre zu die für die
dürfte es jetzt kein grund sein ihn zu
wählen so eine kritik an der
bundespolitik weil wenn man nicht man
sollte halt nicht dinge die man selber
unterstützt
nachher daheim irgendwie kritisieren
oder diffamieren
er ist man im osten sensibler wenn es um
freiheits einschränkungen geht würden
sie sagen und wenn das so ist warum
wählt man dann ausgerechnet die afg oder
glaubt eine bessere freiheit mit der afg
zu finden ja darüber habe ich viel
nachgedacht seit ich diesen satz von
wanderwitz gehört habe denn ich finde da
ist schon was dran also ob das jetzt die
richtige formulierung war und ob man
diese leute deswegen aufgeben muss denn
das ist ja das was er suggeriert im
prinzip die sind für die demokratie
verloren ich bin also da würde ich keine
sekunde zu stimmen aber ich glaube man
darf sich keine illusionen machen dass
die afg gerade in sachsen anhalt ist
noch mal besonders radikal im vergleich
zur bundespolitik und sie ist besonders
erfolgreich im vergleich zur afg etwa in
westdeutschland und dass das jetzt nur
mit löhnen und wie viele ostdeutsche
irgendwo in führungspositionen sind zu
tun hat und mit renten und mit was weiß
ich das hat natürlich auch mit der
diktatur erfahrung zu tun und nur weil
man die selbst recht nicht persönlich
erlebt hat weil nur die eltern die
erlebt haben dass das finde ich das
macht jetzt keinen so großen unterschied
und die afg wähler denen ich begegnet
bin als ich noch für als
berichterstatterin dadurch die ging
gereist bin
die haben das oft so dargestellt dass es
für sie so eine art emanzipations idee
war dass sie auch so ungefähr so einen
denkzettel den man auch dem westen gibt
dass man also ein protest signal was
früher eben wo von früher her gysi
profitiert hat und jetzt eben die afd
und dass die eben sagen das ist unser
mittel gegen bevormundung durch
westdeutsche
politik irgendwie zu kämpfen und das ist
nicht als kompliment gemeint wollte ich
noch kurz zu stellen
das ist ein kompliment weil es im
prinzip bühne zeigt dass sie anders da
eine anfälligkeit für populismus und
extremismus gibt die sicher auch
historisch geprägt ist die auch aus der
ddr erfahrung kommt ich glaube so viel
so ehrlich muss man dann schon sein so
und die antwort von herrn handel auf auf
eine solche these würden sie auch kennen
der würde sagen die afg gibt es in
sämtlichen landtagen dieses landes und
sie ist irgendwie gegründet und sie ist
stark und es gibt wahnsinnig viele
funktionäre aus dem westen die im osten
sind und warum hat eigentlich dieses
land insgesamt zugelassen
das seit 1949 eine solche partei überall
entstehen konnte und stark werden konnte
gut was wird ja nicht zugelassen das
sind ja leute die sich die diebe
schließen sich politisch ich sag jetzt
erst mal neutral zu engagieren in der
auch gerade in der anfangsphase der fdp
war das ja noch eine eher gemäßigte
kraft wieder antrat und aber ich merke
eben dass die afg funktionäre
mehrheitlich westdeutscher viele von
denen westdeutsch in ostdeutschland ja
gezielt dieses ddr gefühl anzapfen also
gerade auch jemand wie blöcke der sagte
ungefähr dafür sind wir nicht auf die
straße gegangen um das jetzt zu erdulden
der selber nie auf die straße gegangen
ist und seine freiheitsrechte zu
erkämpfen
höchstens mal bei einer neonazi-demo
oder so und so das ist schon die die
spielen natürlich auch mit diesem gefühl
die spielen auch mit ein bisschen mit
dieser nostalgie und die zapfen gezielt
dieses gefühl an wir sollen wieder
bevormundet werden und auch die angst
davor dass die diktatur zurückkommen
könnte ziehen ja keine haselhoff hält
ich habs grad schon gesagt die bundes
notbremse immer noch für einen fehler
frage an sie bestätigt er damit nicht
die kritik der afd
nein überhaupt nicht deswegen bin ich
melanie ahmann dankbar die das quartier
ja ein sehr differenzierter weise
dargestellt hat das eine ist völlig
unverantwortlich das wort diktatur zu
benutzen gauland wenn sie meinen es sei
nicht verfassungsgemäß dann ruft man das
bundesverfassungsgericht an das was
geschehen ist
produkt da man hat das gerade
geschildert oder wenn es rechtswidrig
ist ein verwaltungsgerichte auch das ist
während der ganzen partie immer wieder
in hunderten und tausenden fällen
geschehen und die gerichte haben darüber
gut
teilt und das andere ist zu sagen ist
das denn der richtige weg einen solchen
rahmen als bundesgesetzgeber
festzuschreiben oder kann man das in den
ländern wo übrigens vorher die landtage
beteiligt wurden machen und das ist das
aus reiner haseloff gemeint hat dass die
länder das selbst besser entscheiden
können
und ich finde das ist ein sachliches
argument man kann das auch anders sagen
dass man sagt wir brauchen einheitliche
lösungen die jetzt sofort gelten und
dann strikt sind und insofern kann man
das so sehen ich finde wir sind jetzt
doch spürbar an einer stelle wo wir
gesehen haben dass die maßnahmen jetzt
bieten und jetzt läuft auch die
bundesländer aus der den kühnert auch
die spd macht ziemlich mobil gegen den
eigenen koalitionspartner im bund und
auch gegen den bundesgesundheitsminister
kann man der af deser verübeln wenn sie
auch versucht aus politischem kalkül
dieses regierungshandeln massiv zu
kritisieren wir haben es ja eben gerade
noch mal erlebt das ist ja nur der
vorwand das regierungshandeln und sowas
wie die notbremse heranzuziehen
und am ende geht es natürlich darum die
üblichen verdächtigen stichwörter in die
debatte ein zu werfen auf die dann leute
reagieren sollen so was wie diktatur in
dem moment wo man diktatur sagt sind wir
nicht mehr bei der bundesnotarkammer um
21 uhr 22 uhr oder gar nicht sondern da
sind wir bei der sein oder nichtsein
frage ist das eine demokratie oder keine
ja dann moderieren sie dass am ende
wieder ab und sagen dann auch nicht mehr
hilfe von den eigenen leuten geholt aber
die aussage steht im raum und
verselbstständigt sich in den köpfen und
am ende ist es vor allem eins nämlich
wieder eine respektlosigkeit gegenüber
den leuten in sachsen anhalt bei denen
am sonntag gewählt wird denn wir reden
wieder gar nicht darüber was dieses
große flächen land eigentlich ausmachen
hier auf platz drei beim ausbau der
windkraft jetzt im letzten jahr
gestanden haben bei denen es um die
erschließung des ländlichen raums geht
die frage ob die partie mir und
wasserstoff in den nächsten jahren vorne
dran sein werden um die geht es wieder
nicht sondern wir machen die zu so einem
abstimmungs tool für die
bundestagswahlen drei monaten um mal zu
gucken wie die stimmung im lande so ist
aber ich sage ihnen wieder der gender
stern noch die bundes- notbremse stehen
am sonntag auf dem wahlzettel wenn die
leute in die wahllokale gehen sondern
dastehen spd cdu fdp grüne fdp linke und
da kann man sie entscheiden unsere
anlass war ja die korona politik und da
kann man dann trotzdem noch mal
nachfragen helgoland burger
im august des letzten jahres die
pandemie für beendet erklärt und sagte
die kommt auch überhaupt gar nicht
wieder würden sie da jetzt auch im
nachhinein sagen das ist gut dass sie
nicht jeden tag auf diesen mann hören
oder ich würde nicht jede äußerung von
georg wiederholen aber ich bin hier
gerade heftig kritisiert worden dass die
partei nehmen sie doch mal jemand ganz
anderes von heribert prantl aus der
süddeutschen zeitung der ganz ähnlich
formuliert wie wir und sagt ja da wird
er sich gegen verwehren dass er ganz
ähnlich formuliert er überhaupt nicht
sondern er gibt zu dass die
freiheitseinschränkung so wie noch nie
in der bundesrepublik war und dass diese
freiheitseinschränkung eine gefahr
bedeutet und er sagt ganz deutlich diese
freiheitseinschränkung wird sozusagen
als modell verwandt für weitere freiheit
war das doch interessant die
ostdeutschen bürger haben doch viel
krassere freiheitseinschränkung erlitten
das finde ich echt interessant dass sie
bei dem großen verständnis dass die fdp
so eine monstranz vor sich her trägt für
die ostdeutschen wir sind die orte wir
verstehen die ostdeutsche seele und alle
anderen nicht
aber das was in der ddr und
freiheitseinschränkung passiert wurde
das jetzt zu vergleichen mit einer
ausgangssperre von 21 8 21 uhr 20 uhr
das ist doch noch nicht einig sie
versuchen sofort immer wieder was
anderes zu sagen dass eine bahn
berechnen des diktaturen das was wir
hier erleben ist nicht natürlich dazu
sie behaupten nur das sozusagen diese
harte formulierung typisch afd ist und
ich sage es gibt leute aus ihrem
spektrum und herr brandt ist nicht aus
meinem spektrum die das genauso weil sie
haben ja die eine große chance hat ein
zitat genannt in dem er von der diktatur
spricht und das ist genau das was ihnen
gerade vorgeworfen haben sie nutzen
dieses buzzword in dem wissen dass sie
hier als fraktionsvorsitzender der
größten oppositionspartei zur besten
sendezeit im deutschen fernsehen sitzen
um die regierung zu kritisieren ja eine
diktatur zu unterstellen was sind das
für eine diktatur in der sich ein gesetz
von alleine ab schafft nach einem
gewissen ablauf wenn es nicht verlängert
wird
das ist doch albern das weiß doch
wirklich jeder dem geschichtsunterricht
wurde das land hat deswegen album weil
sie es albern finde juristen sehen das
genauso kritisch ist kein
entscheiden das ist ein anderes kritisch
und zwar machen die sich sorgen
hinsichtlich der zukunft wenn man mit
der begründung phantom ii 80 prozent der
bevölkerung dafür gewinnt das grundrecht
auch eingeschränkt werden können in
solchen situation sagen sie wir haben ja
auch urbans irgendwo und die könnten
diese erfahrung nutzen dass es die sorge
um später aus anderen gründen
grundrechte einzuschränken deshalb
müssen wir sehr genau darauf achten wenn
so etwas passiert aus welchen gründen
erzählt uns auch sehr für die
grundrechte einsetzen aber die afg
missbraucht das kannst du auch das
ostdeutsche also der hocker ist nun
wirklich der ist überhaupt kein
ostdeutscher und die art wie er da oft
tritt das kann ich nicht mehr ertragen
muss ich ihnen sagen aber das zweite ist
natürlich dass die ostdeutschen sicher
wirklich benachteiligt fühlen und
natürlich wählen sie auch nach ich sag
mal aus dass sie wissen noch was wehtut
früher tat es eben wie uns zu wählen und
jetzt tut es eben wie die fdp zu bilden
trotzdem lege ich auf 1 großen wert über
eine million hat die cdu an die fdp
verloren über 500.000 die spd vier
200.000 also das ist schon traurig genug
aber so zu tun als ob die in erster
linie von uns cam ist falsch und das
stimmt auch mit sagt das andere bundes
zahlen und ja geil ich wollte gerade
sagen weil sachsen anhalt haben sie
einfach spd und linker die hat und
dadurch dass er die aktive als weniger
als bei der union also mit solchen see
rhetorisch häufiger mit solchen kleinen
tricks sollte man hier nicht operiert
und wissen sie die erfahrung nach der
einheit war schlimm was sich mit
arroganz meinte ist dass man sich die
ddr nicht angesehen hat also vieles
musste weg darüber worauf man ja gar
nicht zu diskutieren
aber wenn man sich die angesehen hätte
und gesagt hätte menschen gibt es ja ein
paar sachen die führen wir einen ganz
deutschland ein
wenn man das gemacht hätte er hätte das
zwei folgen gehabt das selbstbewusstsein
der ostdeutschen mehr gestiegen hätten
gesagt wir haben war das falsche system
aber das heißt ja nicht dass wir nichts
geleistet haben denn wenn du nichts
übernimmst du auch den leuten dass sie
nichts getaugt hat und das zweite wäre
gewesen dass die westdeutschen erlebt
hätten dass durch die vereinigung in
zehn punkten ihre lebensqualität erhöht
das haben die westdeutschen nicht erlebt
das ist sie nicht gegönnt worden ich sag
mal gleichstellung weil man könnte viele
beispiele nennen ist mir jetzt ehrlich
gesagt ein wohnen und rente dass man
darüber noch kämpft machen die reise
jahren nur der slogan herr gysi dir
heißt nehmt den wessis das kommando ja
und nicht dafür kehrt aber gezeigt und
das fand ich richtig und zwar weiß ist
ein 2 das nicht weil es überzogen ja
also das ist alles überzogen ist aber
bei man eben sagen wollte es geht nicht
dass wir da irgendwo dabei sind er sehe
das licht der bundesverwaltung gelingt
die ansonsten mache warum gelingt es
ihnen nicht diese verdoppelten afd
stimmen zu minimieren warum sagt herr
haseloff ich kann hier nicht alleine und
als 100 nämlich meiner partei geben
nein weil wir damit weil wir
international deshalb nicht gefällt mir
das auch als ostdeutsches problem nicht
und national ein problem haben das
problem besteht darin dass
komischerweise autoritäre regime als
effizienter gelten ich halte das für
quatsch aber der eindruck ist mir das
passiert ganz schnell ich erzähle ihnen
ganz kurz ich habe mit erdogan wähler
gesprochen und sie haben mir erklärt ja
der wollte dass das das und das geht bei
ihm ganz schnell während in eurer
demokratie dauert es ewig so wird
gequatscht und so weiter und habe gesagt
ja aber wenn dann wohl dass das und das
will was ihr nicht wollt was macht ihr
dann wählen heißt ja nicht nur ich kann
jemanden wählen ich kann auch jemand
abwählen und wenn man der möglichkeit
entzogen wird so also habe ich dann
versucht mit ihnen zu sprechen und zu
diskutieren das heißt da hat sich was
verschoben und du hast natürlich zu
recht kritisiert die neoliberalen
kapitalismus der markt regelt alles
jedes krankenhaus muss privatisiert
werden als ob im krankenhaus sich in
erster linie rechnen müssen aus muss in
erster linie für gesundheit sorgen aber
das ist natürlich auch unter führung der
spd chef da hat er fast einen halben
punkt der allgäuland das ist natürlich
auch wo ihre verantwortung wahr zum teil
mit passiert wo in dresden kommunale
wohnungen verkauft worden sind in berlin
aber wir gemeinsam gemacht partei
gespalten ja und die eine hälfte sind
die dafür gas ausgetreten
völlig in ordnung ich mir nur darauf
hinweisen es ist ein stück weit der
zeitgeist gewesen das problem ist dass
wir heute 30 jahre später wo sich
jetzt auch wieder ein bisschen relativ
wieder dafür kritisiert dass eine große
lücke haben aber das ist das wo ich
eingangs darauf hinweisen wollte wir
reden jetzt sehr viel über die menschen
im osten als sei das so eine
unveränderliche knetmasse aber da bewegt
sich ja im moment überschuss im jahr
2020 haben wir alleine bei der
gewerkschaft nahrung sieben städten
genuss der fast 100 warnstreiks und
proteste erlebt wo leute bei bautzner
senf bei knorr in riesa bei den
teigwaren gestreikt haben wo es niemals
betriebsräte gegeben aber nicht machen
will stößt bei der spd waren liegt die
spd jetzt nach jüngsten politbarometer
für sammelt bei zehn prozent 11 prozent
und in brandenburg haben wir jede vierte
stimme und in mecklenburg vorpommern
dann sitzt man jede dritte geholt das
ist auch immer in die frage hin ein paar
das in der sachsen anhalt
warum sind die da so erfolgreich ja wenn
man nach mecklenburg ich versuche nur
versuchen nur den eindruck zu
widersprechen und zwar begründet dass
wir es hier mit einem flächen ross
problem sozusagen zu tun haben wir sehen
überall im osten aber zunehmend ja jetzt
auch im westen die person an der spitze
die ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten spielen eine große
rolle
es ist vier jahre her dass das letzte
mal in deutschland ein ministerpräsident
irgendwo abgewählt worden wäre oder eine
ministerpräsidentin ist es damals mit
hannelore kraft gewesen
das heißt menschen orientieren sich
gerade in der krisenhaften situationen
die wir haben zu den führungsfiguren das
kann herr ramelow in thüringen sein das
kann herr kretschmann in baden
württemberg sein das ist manuela
schwesig in mecklenburg vorpommern so
geht davon die hält kretschmann nämlich
allein durch so und dann haben wir in
sachsen anhalt natürlich die situation
und das wird jetzt auch noch mal
spannend für sonntag die regierung hat
sich doch beim letzten mal mit ach und
krach von alleine zusammen gewürfelt da
gibt es eine partei mit der will niemand
zusammen regieren weiß gar nicht ob sie
das selber überhaupt wüsste da gibt es
eine andere partei
das ist die linke die will nur mit ein
paar wenigen parteien zusammen koalieren
mit dem man aber zusammen in diesen
bundesländern nicht auf eine mehrheit
kommt uns zusammen bilden die wenn auch
aus vollkommen unterschiedlichen ecken
kommt einen großen stimmen blog von über
40 prozent der für eine
regierungsbildung nicht in frage kommen
und am ende müssen leute via haselhoff
und vor allem noch viel rechte hre die
das nationale mit dem sozialen versöhnen
wollen und was die nicht alles in papier
schreiben müssen mit meiner partei und
den grünen am ende sogar zusammen
regieren und was ist und am ende steht
die wählerinnen und wähler genau dieser
parteien da und sagen na war ja wieder
eine einheitsregierung am ende war
wieder nur nur breiter gekriegt haben
war ja gar keine klar ich werde es eine
neue modelle singh bundestagswahl hat
deine partei geschworen mit der union
nicht zu koalieren und wohl an landete
sie natürlich werden wir versuchen mal
nach vorne zu schauen und fragen uns
nämlich wohin geht die cdu nicht nur
wegen sachsen anhalt sondern auch weil
die bundeskanzlerin geht wohin geht die
cdu wenn merkel geht wahrscheinlich
wüsste sie dass in teilen auch gern
kruzifix noch mal was ist in der
christen-union los nach 16 jahren merkel
baldrian droht den schwarzen ihr blaues
wunder
totgesagte leben länger und preisen die
alte liturgie
die cdu hat ihren kompass verloren
unsere wählerinnen und wähler soweit
noch vorhanden wissen nicht mehr wofür
wir eigentlich stehen
ich teile ausdrücklich die einschätzung
und friedrich merz brandgefährlich für
den wahlkampf rechtsausleger maßen ist
kandidat für den bundestag
aus der cdu-spitze deshalb werbung für
die konkurrenz
da gibt es ja glücklicherweise noch
kandidaten anderer demokratischer
parteien die vielleicht hoffentlich
gewählt werden und nicht herr maßen so
dass er gar nicht im bundestag kommt
cdu mitglied max otte steht nicht zur
wahl hat aber 2017 afd gewählt er ist
neuer chef der so genannten werte union
ein drahtseilakt für kanzlerkandidat
laschet keine gespräche mit otto aber
auch kein parteiausschlussverfahren
gegen ihn und beten dass der elefant im
raum von alleine verschwindet hat sie
sind wieder dran die cdu nach merkel
reicht also von herrn laschen über maßen
zu hören ist dass das jetzt das gesamte
neue spektrum der partei die cdu steht
in der mitte und ist eben eine
volkspartei aber erlauben sie mir
einsatz und das finde ich weil wir zum
nächsten thema kommen wir haben gerade
jetzt sehr lange über die afg und die
linke gesprochen und über verschiedene
themen und so ein bisschen über die
menschen gesprochen in sachsen anhalt
aber weniger über das was für die
menschen jetzt wichtig ist wie geht es
eigentlich weiter in sachsen anhalt was
ist mit dem thema der bildung der
innovationskraft wie kann man
arbeitsplätze sichern wie kann man
infrastruktur ausbauen
das ist mir ehrlicherweise zu kurz
gekommen ich will das hier noch mal
sagen das ist sachsen anhalt ist vor
allem ein tolles land und ich glaube es
lohnt sich mehr mit den menschen zu
sprechen und vor allem über die
herausforderung die jetzt anstehen ganze
jahr gedanken zu ihrer frage sich schon
ja und dann kommt herr gysi ja kommt der
gysi als vertreter
natürlich wir versuchen sie jetzt noch
ziemlich und konzipieren und gehen sie
einfach davon aus dass wir das tun und
auch konzipieren was sie sagen
die frage ist noch mal die nach ihrer
partei gehirn die jetzt einfach alle mit
dazu ist das jetzt das spektrum das sie
anbieten
zu was die werte union gehört nicht zur
cdu um das noch einmal deutlich zu sagen
ich glaube das müsst ihr jetzt jeder
verstanden haben das ist ein verein der
nicht zu cdu gehört ein beschluss habt
also man kann in beiden gleichzeitig
mitglied sein und es gibt keine probleme
ja man kann auch man kann auch in
anderen vereinen mitglied
wir haben keine vereins listung und es
gibt klare grundsätze der cdu und es
gibt der gesetzgeber hat festgelegt war
man ausgeschlossen werden kann
aus seiner partei und deshalb geht es
darum festzustellen die wertung news
kann teilt der cdu ich glaube dass das
ist ich verstehe kevin köhler versucht
jetzt ein etwas muss ich gerne zugegeben
und billigen parteipolitischen punkt zu
machen um irgendwie die große cdu als
volkspartei in die nähe von
irgendwelchen rechtsextremen zu rücken
und das lasse ich ihm nicht das lasse
ich die nicht der wind das ist jetzt
echt wie ich war der frage möchte ich
nicht durch war das sorgerecht
extremisten bei der frage
rechtsextremistisch macht man keine
späße und bei der frage vor rechts
partei komme ich möchte ich möchte in
zwei sätzen sagen paul ich stelle aber
deine persönliche klare linie
sogar die der meisten in eurer
parteiführung und erst recht die der
meisten eurer mitglieder mit manchen
davon 70 in einem kommunalparlament
zusammen überhaupt nicht in frage
aber du kannst nicht von der hand weisen
das ist etwas mehr als ein jahr her ist
dass im benachbarten bundesland von
sachsen anhalt in thüringen abgeordneten
gemeinsam mit der kfd ein fdpler zum
ministerpräsidenten gewählt haben dass
seitdem keine anständige aufarbeitung
dessen stattgefunden hat dass die leute
von denen reiner haseloff jetzt sagt ihr
kurs ist nicht der seine dass man der
richtung afd bringt das die hinter ihm
auf der landesliste auf den plätzen
dahinter direkt 345 usw sitzen da kannst
du doch nicht ernsthaft behaupten diese
diskussion seiner mediengewandte frage
vor so einer landtagswahl
ob da wirklich alle stehen nicht nur
persönlich im zweifel auch nicht armin
laschet aber ob da in sachsen anhalt
alle stehen wenn ein schwieriges
ergebnis am sonntagabend haben
dabei sind immer ein gemeiner haseloff
er war eine haseloff ist der garant
dafür in sachsen-anhalt also haben wir
eine klare vorher klare politik eine
klare das ist doch nicht wahr weil eine
klare politik haben schrift geschrieben
und haben dafür plädiert dass man das
nationale mit dem sozialen verbinden
soll
also herr haseloff kann
dieses afd tabu sicherlich halten würden
sie denn da auch schwören dass das für
die gesamte cdu sachsen-anhalts gilt her
ist sie mir die linie ist klar für die
cdu deutschlands und für die ganze cdu
sachsen anhalt keine zusammenarbeit
keine koalition oder ähnliches mit der
afg und die menschen haben jetzt die
wahl in sachsen anhalt soll es irgendwie
nach links rutschen sachsen anhalt oder
soll es nach industrie oder soll es an
als mit einem vernünftigen bürgerlichen
politik mit einem ministerpräsidenten
der die sprache der menschen spricht in
der mitte bleiben das ist die wahl am
sonntag um die ihre los geht s zitieren
nochmal zwei sätze von herrn ott sagte
rein persönlich ist ja der ansicht dass
die cdu die möglichkeit für bürgerliche
koalition mit der fdp geben ausloten
sollte und übrigens war die wahl von
kemmerich eine glanzstunde der
demokratie
und da würden hochrangige mitglieder
gerne mit der fdp zusammenarbeiten aber
man traut sich das nur privat
auszusprechen ist das nicht mehr richtig
oder könnte das richtig sein wie groß
ist ihre sorge wirklich hat sie mir das
ist das ist natürlich völlig falschen
ist nicht die position der cdu das mal
klar zu sagen es gibt in jeder partei
leider gottes auch solche
persönlichkeiten wie herrn sarrazin in
der spd hans otto bei uns der
gesetzgeber legt klar fest wie wie wie
man jemanden aus einer partei
ausschließt ich aber ich finde ich muss
ganz ehrlich sagen frau in sisi wir
haben 400.000 mitglieder sie nehmen
jetzt ein mitglied das keine funktion in
der partei
alle funktionen man auch einen grund
warum jetzt diese prominente
organisationen die vor allem aus cdu
mitgliedern besteht also es ist
irgendeine art ihn ja gewählt und das
leben vor cdu-mitglieder und cdu
vereinfachen dass ein verein von
cdu-mitgliedern ist weiß nicht
einzutreten der werte union man muss
entweder cdu mitglied sein oder
ein um mit der cdu verwandelten mit
einer unterorganisation mitglied sein
das hat doch niemand überprüft ich muss
das jetzt mal weil es hier wirklich um
wirklich wichtige dinge geht
frau dr man das hat niemand überprüft
ich weiß nicht ob sie es getan haben ich
habe es mit 4500 mitglieder ob die alle
cdu-mitglieder sind ja also ich
bestreite dass ich bin mir sicher dass
das nicht das land auch
bundestagsabgeordnete der cdu wieder
mitglied sind in der werte union hans
georg maas und das ist vor kurzem mit
dem namen wollte er sagen von hans-georg
maßen wissen wir aus einem spiegel
-interview mai 21 was politiker aus uns
machen wollen sind untertanen die auf
die 20 uhr nachrichten schauen um zu
hören was die politische elite
entschieden hat und er würde seinem
jüngeren ich raten diesen staat und den
bürgern wieder zurückzugeben und in
teilen zurück zu geben und ihn
zurückzuholen vom politischen
establishment
mai 2021 das ist hans-georg maßen der
ist nun auch cdu mitglied und der ist in
südthüringen aufgestellt als die letten
oder auch da er zehn jahre wäre es toll
wenn man etwas von ihnen hören würde
ist das in ihren augen ok bin doch hier
ist es in ihren augen ok oder würden sie
auch sagen hans georg maßen
da ist die brandmauer aber schon
dunkelrot nein also es ist so dass hans
georg maßen man muss ja nicht alles
teilen was er sagt was ich gut verstehe
er hat sich vorgestellt in dem wahlkreis
er hat dort diese ausstellung für sich
entschieden er hat dort aber auch noch
mal klar gesagt dass es dass es
überhaupt keine zusammenarbeit mit der
ard geben kann das war wichtig glaube
ich für viele die leute auch abgestimmt
haben deswegen ist dort eine
positionierung klar er ist auch nicht
mehr mitglied der werte union hat seine
mitgliedschaft ruhen lassen gut aber sie
nochmal die zu diesen äußerungen die
sind jetzt wochen alt da sagen sie das
spricht nicht genug für sie und er lässt
seine mitgliedschaft in der werte union
ruhen und damit ist er ein wertvolles
cdu mitglied aber jetzt dürfen sie jetzt
freuen sie dürfen jetzt auch nicht die
dinge jetzt etwas anders darstellen als
ich sie gesagt habe ich teile diese
aussage
die ja gesagt hat überhaupt nichts sie
haben mich gefragt nach der nach der
frage zusammenarbeit mit der afg und
hans-georg maßen und da hab ich ihn
wieder gegeben was er dazu gesagt hat
und das halte ich für richtig keine
zusammenarbeit kein millimeter auf die
afg zu die aussage sonsten teile ich
überhaupt nicht das verstärkt er den
frust den menschen haben gegenüber
berlin aber das ist noch mal eine andere
frage ob man etwas teilt oder ob man mit
der afg zusammenarbeit möchte melanie
amann marco wanderwitz sagt den maßen
aufzustellen in südthüringen ist irrsinn
funktioniert in ihren augen die
brandmauer nach rechts in der cdu
funktioniert sie immer weniger kann man
das noch präzise beschreibt also ich
wollte einmal nur kurz klatscht es war
kein interview von herrn maßen bei uns
nur weil damit wir auch nen klagefreudig
es war etwas wasser in irgendeinem
videopodcast gesagt hat aber zu ihrer
frage ich finde schon
also es gab glaube ich kein weg dass die
cdu das komplett hätte verhindern können
dass er antritt wenn die ihn unbedingt
wollten aber was mich ein bisschen
beunruhigt ist das noch nicht mal der
versuch unternommen wurde er offenbar
oder zumindest weiß ich von keinem
versuche zehn jahr kann das gerne
klarstellen dass man so jemanden hin
schickte er als sich die kandidatur
abzeichnete mit den leuten redet er sagt
können wir nicht jemand anders finde
kann man nicht gleich den ostdeutschen
kandidaten oder eine kandidatin finden
ist das wirklich der einzige wollt ihr
den wirklich auch als offenes gespräch
gar nicht als ukas irgendwie aus der
parteizentrale oder so da gibt es ja
immer noch so zwischentöne und ich finde
es auch ehrlich ich würde schon sagen
dass die linie der cdu da klar ist das
ist eine bürgerliche partei die hat aber
rechtsausleger wie herrn maßen nunmal
zulässt dass die zu symbolfiguren wäre
und den unterschied